we have looked at polynomials cows X
this is such a how much to teach ok can
I try and do this
we have done polynomial functions we
need trig functions we did a little bit
we looked at log functions just very
briefly okay Shh let's offer actually I
mean these are really easy I probably
could have done with a portrait parking
spot an exponential function okay I
won't worry too much about other bases
because they're not really that
interesting is where all the acts is
happening you differentiate and what do
you get so this is a fun relationship so
what would you expect the primitive of e
to the X to be
plus a constant right okay to you like
that
boring alright well let's let's add in
some other stuff okay sure
e to the 2x just regular chain rule to
differentiate good than that direction
we're going to multiply by the
derivative of the inside okay right so
if I were to age a different shape think
about where did this thing where copper
on right
well instead of multiplying here we're
getting the theme by now right I'm gonna
do by okay okay no apart from that there
are not all that many interesting
variations about this because a lot of
things can be differentiated okay
like say it's okay
what is the do but there's no nice sleek
thing that that that thing came from
right because you have to multiply it be
a weird thing to get rid of it we a
divided by 2x why do you try it if I
started with this what was your word to
have e to the X square and you've
divided by 2x right what happens yeah it
breaks bad it doesn't it so you did this
so you like V - yes that's - - you V -
all over V squared
okay sir I've got 4x squared there -
these doesn't look all that great right
suddenly suddenly doesn't look like it's
good to get there does it you can take
out your factor of e then x squared but
it doesn't make it all that much better
take out a - well which is really going
to improve things
- big deal okay thing is this however
you do get to have some interesting
questions like this now I want to rather
than show you answer trading I want you
to have a work at this okay x times e to
the x okay so this is a product okay
it's not changeable but you can
differentiate this you wouldn't expect
it to be something easy to
anti-differentiate
okay but I want you to spend a minute
with it have a think see if you could
guess what's the prudent function where
it came from
okay
these trolls patrol almost almost almost
planners you know re-plumbing a friend's
house so that it puts beer out of its
taps instead but not quite there
that's it but mr. Boylan who would ever
have any ideas let me have a look
the great thing about this by the way is
if you have something you can test it
out
I'll see you quick because you don't
have a differentiator so if you think
you have a premium then it's easy to
verify with your right alone
that's
we've got one answer so far right so
it's just this even in us can
because I don't know what it is because
it's it's this on the other hand even
though it doesn't look like you know a
nice easy thing you guys but they don't
know enough know enough about calculus
in general to actually work out what
this okay I think that was so he's not
gonna do it and actually you you get
questions like this I think I sort of I
think I was mentioning it like compute
one today pot a Oliver question might be
take that function and don't find the
primitive but instead find the
derivative which you know quite well how
to do right so let's do this
so this would be this would be product
okay um do we think what's this
okay yes I'm gonna slow it down just
favorite catch that this is products
rule right okay it's a V u - V you -
yeah times 1 + u v - so far so good
okay yeah here's the interesting thing
okay I'm gonna take this oh look at this
line right and I'm you know the next
question pop Bay would be hence find the
premium all of this thing okay how could
you find the premium from this well the
key thing you want to keep in mind is
that differentiating right to the
interview an age differentiating really
are reversed processes so if I can
differentiate both sides of this
equation okay I should be able to a to
differentiate both sides of this
equation it's just another operation
just like multiplying everything by PI
or squaring well or something like that
okay so remember this is the thing that
I want to Eddie different here yes okay
so if I want a differentiate this I have
to add to differentiate everything else
as well but I know how to enter
differentiate these two don't I you
think about it let's let's do this one
it's easy okay here from the difference
between these two lines is I'm
anti-differentiating everything then e
to the X turns into what imagine
differentiate what's this thing turning
to when I ante differentiated yeah it's
it's well this is gonna be an edgy
different shape and then differentiate
so those two should just cancel each
other out
it's almost like you know experience
squared just taking the square root or
multiply my two divided by two
these are reverse operations right so
this just turns into this okay
now a lot of been left over is the anti
derivative right the primitive function
on this guy right so involved oh yeah
whatever it is inside well if I just
want capital F on its own all why not do
the rearrange so does that make sense
but did you see what I got it we sorted
you decide the primitive of XE to the X
it is X e to the X - okay I know that I
really should've added in here okay and
it's plus Co - see it doesn't matter
because it's just a constant it doesn't
matter which wasn't even right that's
kind of weird you know that as you
differentiate you add this thing and as
you're a to differentiate you take it
away yeah it's kind of funny
but these are these are creators of
exponential functions which should be
expected to I'm glad we had that
conversation which Tepe do you want ng
franching each term independently yeah
so I don't with these two because I know
what they will tell you to I didn't know
what this return into but I gave it I
gave a name capital F whatever it is
okay but then when I found out
Kappas over here and then these two I
already dealt with all I need to do is
just rearrange a little bit and get
capital F on its either that's chasing
something that's all I do
and I can test it out by differentiating
hey I'm gonna get I'm gonna get that -
because it just turns into itself when I
differentiate well okay good question
now apparently by anti differentiated
three different things yes
so shouldn't I therefore have three
extra constants for all of these
primitives that are thought right
I should have cost them for this one I
should have a constant for this one and
I should have a constant for this one if
all of these constants if all of them
are real okay then I can just add or
subtract them all together you know for
instance C 1 plus C 2 plus C 3 or
subtract one of them it wouldn't matter
which one right and I can just pull all
of them C which will itself also be a
real number right and because none of
these are gonna change they not
variables that you know flip flop around
a bit value these things not going to
so I might as well just treat it as just
one super constant yeah it wouldn't
matter if one matter whether it's
possible because it's just some constant
and I don't care what its value is so
plus or minus let me do